>> I WILL BE SENDING A LETTER T
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ASKIN
FOR A CRIMINAL REFERRAL BECAUSE
HE HAS LIED TO CONGRESS, WE HAV
SCIENTISTS THAT WILL LINE UP BY
THE DOZENS TO SAY THAT THE
RESEARCH HE WAS FUNDING WAS A
FUNCTION, HE IS DOING THIS
BECAUSE HE HAS A SELF INTEREST
TO COVER HIS TRACKS AND TO COVE
HIS CONNECTION TO THE LAB.
>> THAT IS KENTUCKY SENATOR RAN
FALL THREATENING TO SEND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT A CRIMINAL
REFERRAL AGAINST DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI.
THE REPUBLICAN SENATOR PRESSING
ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF COVEN AND
THE FUNDING OF THE LABORATORY
AND CHINA.
THE CHIEF MEDICAL ADVISOR IS
STANDING FIRM DENYING ANY
WRONGDOING.
HAVE TO SEE IT.
WATCH FOR IT.
>> KNOWING THAT IT'S A CRIME TO
LIE TO CONGRESS, DO YOU WISH TO
RETRACT YOUR STATEMENT OF MAY
11TH WHEN YOUR CLAIMED THE
NIH NEVER FUNDED THE RESEARCH I
WUHAN?
>> I HAVE NEVER LIED BEFORE THE
CONGRESS, AND I DO NOT RETRACT
THAT STATEMENT.
>> YOU TAKE AN ANIMAL VIRUS AND
UKRAINE THAT YOU'RE SAYING
THAT'S NOT TO GAIN A FUNCTION.
>> THAT IS CORRECT, SENATOR PAUL
, YOU DO NOT KNOW WHAT YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
>> THEY TOOK ANIMAL VIRUSES THA
ONLY OCCUR IN ANIMALS, AND THEY
INCREASED THEY'RE
TRANSMISSIBILITY TO HUMANS, I
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN SAY
THAT'S NOT A GAIN OF FUNCTION.
YOUR DANCING AROUND THIS BECAUS
YOU'RE TRYING TO OBSCURE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR 4 MILLION
PEOPLE DYING AROUND THE WORLD.
>> YOU ARE IMPLYING THAT WHAT W
DID WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DEATHS OF INDIVIDUALS, I TOTALL
RESENT THAT, AND IF ANYBODY IS
LYING HERE, SENATOR, IT IS YOU.
>> HARRIS, I HAD SAID SENT
OFTENTIMES BEFORE ONE OF THE
GREATEST CASUALTIES OF THIS
PANDEMIC HAS BEEN MEDICINE AND
SCIENCE.
WE LIVE IN A WORLD WHERE WE ARE
DESPERATE FOR SOMETHING TO RISE
ABOVE THE POLITICAL DAM,
SOMETHING WE CAN TRUST AND
BELIEVE IN.
EIGHT USED TO BELIEVE MEDICINE.
I DON'T KNOW HIM, I KNOW RAND
LITTLE BIT.
I KNOW IT MAKES FOR GREAT TV TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION IN FIVE
MINUTE INCREMENTS ON TELEVISION
BUT WHY DON'T YOU MEET WITH ONE
ANOTHER.
WHY DON'T YOU JUST GO, NO
CAMERAS, YOU BOTH ARE MDS, GO
SIT DOWN, I DON'T HAVE A FRIEND
WHO UNDERSTANDS GAIN OF FUNCTION
.
MAYBE MY FRIENDS ARE JUST NOT
THAT SMART, BUT WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT THAT.
WHAT WE TALK ABOUT IS HOW DO WE
SURVIVE THIS LOOMING COMING
SEASON OF DISQUIET THAT IS
COMING BACK.
IT WOULD BE GREAT IF WE COULD
RELY ON MEDICINE.
GO TALK ABOUT THIS IN PRIVATE
FIRST, THAT'S WHAT THE BIBLE
SAYS TO DO AND THAT WOULD BE A
GOOD IDEA FOR BOTH OF Y'ALL.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THIS DISCUSSION AND JOSH
ROGAN FROM THE WASHINGTON POST
ALSO IS HE IN CONTRIBUTOR
TWEETED OUT LAST NIGHT HE SAID
THAT THE NIH WAS FUNDING GAIN O
FUNCTION RESEARCH AT THIS LAB,
BUT WHEN THE NIH REPORTEDLY DID
ACCORDING TO THIS WASHINGTON
POST COLUMNIST IS THEY DIDN'T
CLASSIFY IT AS GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH BECAUSE BY NOT
CLASSIFYING IT, THEN THEY GOT
AWAY FROM HAVING THE OVERSIGHT
MECHANISMS MECHANISM THAN THAT
NIH REQUIRES IF YOU ARE FUNDING
IT.
WHY DOES THAT MATTER?
NUMBER ONE IT MATTERS BECAUSE I
THEY ARE FUNDING THE RESEARCH I
THE LABS OR ANYWHERE AROUND THE
WORLD WHERE I THINK IT'S PROVEN
THEY WERE, AND THEY'RE NOT
DECLARING IT, IN ORDER TO GET
AROUND AND OVERSIGHT MECHANISM,
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THEY STOP
DOING IT, IT'S ALSO SECONDLY
IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHY DO WE HAV
THIS OVERSIGHT IN PLACE?
COULD WE IF WE HAD PROPER
OVERSIGHT OF THE GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH GOING ON IN
THIS LAB, WOULD WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
ORIGINS OF COVID KNOWS WHICH WE
DO NOT KNOW, IF THE TEAM FROM
THE LAB, BUT SIGNS ARE POINTING
TO THERE.
BUT FINALLY, THERE IS ONE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF THIS AND
IT'S NOT FAUCI, IT'S THE CHINES
COMMUNIST PARTY.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE NO MATTER
WHAT WE'RE ARGUING ABOUT IN THE
UNITED STATES OUR EFFORTS ARE
FOCUSED ON GETTING THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE ORIGINS OF
COVID.
>> WE WANT TO GET TO THIS.
YOU HAD BROUGHT UP THE COVID
VACCINE.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN STEVE
SCULLY'S IS TALKING ABOUT WHY H
IN FACT FINALLY CHOSE, HE WAS
WAITING, HE WAS DELAYING HIM HE
FINALLY CHOSE TO GET THE COVID
VACCINE NOW.
WATCH.
>> MONTH AGO I HAD TESTED FOR
THE ANTIBODIES.
ULTIMATELY WITH THE NEW DELTA
VARIANTS VARIANCE, YOU'RE SEEN
LOT OF HOSPITALS IN THE LAST FE
WEEKS INTERESTING THE CASES GO
UP.
IT'S NOT TO THE ALARMING LEVEL
WE SAW LAST YEAR BY ANY STRETCH
BUT YOU DO SEE ABOUT 95-98
PERCENT OF PEOPLE IN THE
HOSPITAL FOR COVID THAT ARE
PEOPLE THAT ARE UNVACCINATED.
I WAS READY TO GET THE VACCINE,
I ALWAYS FELT IT WAS SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE, I APPLAUD WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMPETED TO BRING
MULTIPLE VACCINES TO THE MARKET
IN THE QUICKEST TIME EVER, BUT
IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY CUT
CORNERS, THEY TESTED IT ON
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE BEFORE YOU
GOT THE FDA CONDITIONAL USE
APPROVAL, SO IT'S SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE.
I TOOK IT AND I WANTED TO TAKE
THE PICTURE TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE.
>> WHILE WE DISCUSSED THIS, AND
KAYLEIGH, I WANT TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THIS.
BUT LOOK, THIS IS CONGRESSMAN
SCHOOLEY'S ON SUNDAY GETTING HI
FIRST COVID SHOT, HE SAYS HE'S
GETTING THE TWO SHOT SERIES SO
HE WILL BE BACK IN 21 OR 28 DAY
DEPENDING ON WHICH WHEN HE GOT
FRED.
>> LIGHT CONGRESSMAN STEVE
SCULLY'S, I HAD COVID 19 EVEN
THOUGH I WAS A SYMPTOMATIC, I
WENT AND GOT THE VACCINE FOR A
FEW REASONS, FIRST LET ME SAY I
START PRESIDENT TRUMP OVERSEE
THE PROCESS AND HE APPOINTED, H
APPOINTED THE PEOPLE.
I GOT THE VACCINE BECAUSE ONE,
IT KEEPS ME FROM GETTING THE
VARIANCE, NUMBER TWO, EVEN IF
YOU GET A VARIANT YOUR 95
PERCENT LESS LIKELY TO BE
HOSPITALIZED.
>> IT IS HIGHER THAN THAT FOR A.
>> AND EVEN MORE IMPORTANT THAN
ANY OF THAT, IS IT REDUCES YOUR
RISK OF TRANSMITTING THE VIRUS
SO IF YOU HAVE A GRANDMOTHER,
GRANDFATHER, OR PARENT, DO IT
FOR THEM IF NOT FOR YOURSELF.
>> WHEN YOU TALK TO PEOPLE, WE
TALK ABOUT THIS ALL THE TIME,
I'M NOT A DOCTOR, HAS TREY SAID
WE'RE NOT ALL EPIDEMIOLOGIST
BREAKING DOWN MRNA AND TRNA.
BUT AT THE BASELINE POINT WE
WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S RIGHT
FOR US.
I AM SO CONFUSED ABOUT THE
MESSAGING GAMETE OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WHY CANTLEY SIMPLY STAY WITH TH
PEOPLE ON THE PLANE GOING FROM
TEXAS TO DC DID WAS WRONG.
THEY WERE LAUGHING FEDERAL
REGULATIONS FOR BEING IN THE AIR
, NO MATTER WHAT THEY'RE
VACCINATION STATUS, THE REST OF
US WEAR A MASK.
WHETHER WE LET THAT PROCESS WER
NOT.
WHY GIMP IS SAY THE PROVING
GROUND WILL BE AT THE AT THE FDA
, WE WILL TELL THEM TO GIVE
FULL APPROVAL, SCIENTIFICALLY
THINK THEY GET THERE FROM THIS
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION.
80 PERCENT OF THE PEOPLE I HAVE
TALKED TO THEY SAID WHY DON'T
THEY MAINSTREAM IT LIKE EVERY
OTHER DRUG GREAT IF YOU READ TH
BACK OF BOTTLES OF THE
ANTI-INFLAMMATORIES, THERE ARE
LOT OF INDICATORS FOR WHY YOU
MIGHT WANT TO CHOOSE A DIFFEREN
DRUG GRADE WHY CAN'T THE WHITE
AT THE LOOK AT THIS.
CAN GET A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HAV
HESITATION POINT OUT WHY ISN'T
THE FDA, WHY HAVEN'T THEY
APPROVED IT YET.
IT ONLY SERVES TO IGNITE MORE
QUESTIONS IN THE AMERICAN PEOPL
ESPECIALLY WITH THAT MIXED
MESSAGING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION TRICKLES DOWN TO
THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL WHERE
IN LA COUNTY, THEY ARE STILL
DEMANDING PEOPLE WEAR A MASK
INDOORS AND OUTDOORS, ESPECIALL
TO COME WHAT THEY CALLED THE
PANDEMIC OF FUN VACCINATION.
PART I THINK THAT'S WHY STEVE
SCULLY'S AT LEAST HE IS SENDING
A CLEAR MESSAGE ABOUT THE
EFFICACY APPEARED WE TALKED
ABOUT THE BLOOD OF MIGRANTS ON
THE BORDER, 38 PEOPLE IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY IN HAITI HAVE
BEEN VACCINATED.